so looking games are very very tricky
and they are for people at all levels
and I'd say the knowledge level there is
a lot it's like there are some people
who will know their basic endings pretty
well even when they were younger or like
less experienced other people just don't
learn them and even though they become
like 2,000 2,200 even higher they still
don't know a lot of their basic end
games but the nice thing about these end
games is that they can be studied at
almost any level so one of the things
I'd say about like the end games is that
okay I mean they're a little bit
different it's not as much you know a
lot of the concern is about whether
you're able to clean up on something
like this but I'd say in work end games
one of the most important things to
remember is that if for four it happens
kind of for both sides but especially
for the side that does have the extra
pawn is whether your King has shelter so
you guys know what I mean by this
concept if not that's fine just let me
know Judy are you guys aware of this
shelter if you have any a lot of people
have heard of it but the main thing is
if black keeps checking you does your
King have anywhere to hide so in this
position believe it or not so actually
I'm going to start with this position
because this is the same position with
black to move and black can actually
draw pretty simply here and the way it
happens is that black simply gives us
check on a eight King has to move up and
blacks just going to keep checking you
the problem you have is that the King
has nowhere to hide now you can't just
check forever regardless right the King
can try to approach the rook but what
this is what will happen if first of all
white tries to approach from here it
doesn't really work out because after
this check can the King approach further
the pawn would hang so the King can try
to do it this way but once the King gets
sufficient distance from the pawn it
becomes very easy to win
so here
to draw I should say so here black has a
draw immediately anyone sorry do I have
the wrong position there I don't think
there's a knight anywhere I was like
whoa what's going on with the screens
rook f6 e 6 there we go and then you're
just going to collect this pawn right so
you see how simple it is actually like
if you don't have shelter for your King
it's really hard to win with extra pawn
because the problem is the rook can just
keep checking you until your King has to
go too far away like if the King goes
all the way down to d2 like the
likelihood of winning is pretty small
right because the pawn is simply not
going to win by itself
so having shelter is extremely important
so going back to the first position here
white can create a little bit of shelter
for himself and that's actually how you
win this position it's a technique
called building a bridge so the way it
works is you first of all give a check
this check is very important because if
you don't then again you just don't have
any place to hide with your king so for
example if King f6 you have you actually
can win immediately here
and note how the reason why this wins is
because you actually have shelter now
this king shields your own King and if
the rook tries to check you you can just
Queen and the Queen's unstoppable I mean
black can try a trick like rook here
threatening mate oh no it's not even
made look can cover so you can just get
a queen all right so the black king will
usually just move away let's say here
and now your goal what's the difference
between this position and the previous
one can you guys figure it out hmm
that's um okay ah yeah so you have the
f7 square which is nice because if the
rook starts checking you from here your
King can escape but here's my question
if black doesn't if black doesn't do
much so say for example if you play King
f7 here how are you going to win if I
just keep checking you from the back
so you might be able to play something
like King g8 but the rook can come back
it's not entirely clear and if you try
to come up and the problem is you don't
have shelter right your King has nowhere
to hide so when you get to this position
you actually have to thank you very much
you actually have to get get your king
shelter with a technique called building
a bridge I didn't make up this name it's
just what it's called so that what you
start with is this move looks like a
pretty harmless move right but the whole
idea is that like sets a block passes a
move either with King eight say let's
say black just plays King h7 how do you
think you win
all right so you're threatening
checkmate end to Queen the pawn by the
way it's the most forcing move for the
guys at the previous lecture give a
check which is almost all of you so what
now got to come up right otherwise
you're just going back now what is this
rook going to do for you okay but how
does it block the check so I'm going to
give you a check now
well you can't let go your pawn right
going back doesn't help you so where
else can you go
so here for example so now if I give
check here what do you do where does the
king hide g5 if I don't know because
then the rook comes back but why did I
put the rook here it doesn't help block
the check here but if I move a little
closer so where can I move this a little
closer to the rook the only one square
right I mean all right
glad we've got that one figure it out
but what's the whole point that after
the check you can do what now
aha there you go
and this is called building a bridge and
it's one of the most it's one of the
main components in a rook endgame like
if someone's going to show you basic
rook and pawn and game's is one of the
first things you should get shown so if
you learn how to master this technique
that's already a major start and row
components actually so so yeah so
building a bridge etc however one of the
things I like to do in these positions
I'll notice like a lot of students will
for example know this technique but if I
try to mess with them a little bit all
of a sudden they have lots of trouble
winning so one of the things I like
people to do is get comfortable in these
positions because there's often some
little detail they don't know or if
their opponent doesn't follow the game
plan they have trouble winning so for
example in this position how do you guys
win if I simply wait this is a
possibility that's often forgotten in
the endgame and it's possible to use it
from both perspectives for example if
you're on the defense in a middle game
it's very rare you can just pass a move
right because your opponent can almost
always play a move that improves their
position in the endgame there are fewer
pieces right so oftentimes your opponent
actually doesn't have a move that
improves their position at least
significantly so waiting is a very good
technique both if you're defending and
if you're on offense because your free
run offense sometimes your opponent has
their pieces on the perfect defense of
squares so you just waste a move and you
make them move one of their pieces so
this is a technique that's often
forgotten about when people play in
games so blacks trying to defend just by
saying all right how are you going to
Queen with your King on f6 you can play
King f7 but then I'll start giving
checks again rookie names can be some of
the most annoying things because like
when the rooks just start giving you
check and you don't have shelter it's
like you just you sometimes it prevents
you from winning some really basic stuff
remember though your pond you have to
hold on to your pond but you have the
right idea
you need your rook to be a little closer
to the king your king cannot move though
so what can move AHA and this is a very
nice move because now you're going to
just going to shield with rookie five
and there's nothing black can do so for
example if King h6 you just play rook e5
if check you hide here and Queen cannot
be stopped it's a pretty it's not as
easy as it looks right but the thing is
once you get the hang of these things
why don't you learn these techniques
really well they actually become second
nature like you can do it without
thinking but it takes a while they look
pretty unnatural right this isn't like
normal chess that's why I like the
endgame you have to devote specific time
to it just because it's so unlike any
other part of the game I mean how often
the middle game you're going to be like
running your King around in circles and
then putting your rook back and forth it
just doesn't happen but an endgame um it
happens all the time so okay let's go
back so for example one of the ways I'll
mess with a student for example is say
they play they play here because yeah if
the King is here for example playing
rook here doesn't work because the King
attacks the rook right you can't you
can't shield right away so this is the
magical square for the rook but one of
the things I'll do the students will say
all right I'll just attack it what are
you going to do now you wouldn't believe
how some of them flip out they're like
wait you can't check my rook it's not
it's not in the rules so how do you win
after King h5
RUP g7 okay cuz yeah one of the things
you want to do if you face a move you
don't know and let's face it when you're
just starting out learning in games it's
pretty much everything right you have to
try to figure things out so one of the
ways you can figure it out is if your
opponent does something like for example
say you're in a position you know is
winning and they try something a little
different
oftentimes they may prevent the idea
that often wins but you want to be aware
of other ideas that win besides the one
you know like building the bridge you
guys know now right but they're trying
to interfere with building the bridge so
you have to find another way to win so
yeah rook g7 is a nice way to do it and
this will almost always work so the idea
is that if the King goes back to attack
the rook where do you what do you do now
mm-hmm so and now the problem is if the
rook checks you here you can shield with
the rook again shelter is the most
important thing in these engines black
can try a trick I can give you check
here and now what right do not Queen
please allowing rook takes check it's a
very painful when you have the win and
you let it slip like this it's happened
everyone but yeah do not let it happen
I'm sure it has it's very easy to do
that's why you keep your guard up all
the time even in the hen game you know
most forcing moves right okay so King of
seven and now there's no way to stop
this Queen like if black tries to wait
you can just play here you know it's
it's quite easy to win once you have
something like this you know where the
rook is just trying like hope hoping to
try for one little tactic all right so
basically Cena so now I'm going to get a
little bit more complicated and show you
a few different things all right but a
lot of them if you know the Lucena it
actually gets so yeah this one I showed
you so if it was black to play then it's
a draw because of this check right the
King is closer so you can't hide on the
F file
so the checks from afar however one of
the key checking distances now
memorization is really hard and chess
and I try to make it so people have to
member
as little as possible like memorizing
that whole sequence is hard to do so one
of the ways I try to learn it is by
learning by the ideas so you learn the
idea of building the bridge with the
rook on the fourth right or if you're
black the rook would be on the fifth but
you get what I mean right
so you learn this technique with the
bridge with the rook on the fourth if
the King approaches the rook you bring
the rook here and then bring the King
here so your rook and pawn shield your
king but one of the things I'd memorize
is that when your opponent's giving
checks with the rook from the side in
this particular situation but even from
the front sometimes the key square that
black needs is five squares so you see
how here black can play rook a eight and
it's a and there are three squares in
between the king and the rook it's a
five square a total right that's how
much black needs in order to have enough
distance because here black cannot apply
cannot approach this way because there's
one there's one file too many in between
the king and the rook and the rook will
always be able to get back let me show
you what I mean the next one this
position is actually a very easy win
even with black to move the reason being
that a black tries to give check the
rook is only four squares away see you
now
and now you play here you can't check
along here anymore you guys see that so
you'd have to go somewhere like along
here here for example and the King comes
back and the Queen so we're right by the
way if I'm going too fast if you're not
following if you have a question just
please let me know if I'm if I'm going
skipping over everything it's not always
so useful if so but okay so you see how
the four squares is not enough but when
you have one extra square it makes all
the difference
so knowing counting how many squares
there are between the rook and the King
is actually something which is really
useful so okay the next one I'm going to
show you so I showed you one of the key
winning positions which is called the
Lucina position where you have the King
on the 8th the pawn on the seventh and
you build the bridge
it's called the lucena position there
was a guy named Mussina then
so this one is called the Philidor now
there are about a million things named
after Philidor in chess
we've seen it I think it's just the one
position with Philidor there's tons of
them but in rookie names there's
something called the Philidor draw now
this is a technique you use to draw
against the king in one pot now here you
can see the King in one pawn is farther
back your king is in front which is the
best place right you want your King B to
be able to blockade this pawn and these
situations are almost always drawn
however it can get very tricky if your
King gets forced out from in front of
the pawn but there's a way you can
prevent white from doing this so there's
an immediate technique to draw do any of
you know it first of all so if not try
to try to figure it out spend a couple
minutes figure out how you can prevent
so I can tell you what White's idea is
White's idea is going to be to play
something like king here and then the
idea is to be able to check you and
force your King out so how can you
prevent white from accomplishing you can
give a check it's a forcing move I like
you got to look at it but I play King
here and now I'm threatening rook h8
which is pretty powerful so the problem
is now you you really you know you
almost never want a passive rook when
you're defending there are occasions
where it's okay but in general if you're
not sure don't do it because the rook
here actually loses immediately because
I just play here and this check is going
to be deadly you have to play here to
avoid made and then I win your rook so
passive rook again that means a rook
just on the back rank defending ins mate
for example that can't really move
anywhere passive rook passive rooks and
rook endings are def you almost always
want an active rook so active means
you're out from the side you're trying
to check you're not just tied down to
one square or one file so rook a six
there's an excellent move here the point
being that it cuts the King off so
there's no tricky moves like king f6
there's no King e6 and basically here is
where the waiting technique comes into
play if white plays here you just wait
back and forth
back and forth back and forth white can
do nothing like white can try to trade
rooks but it's hard to do because
there's no square first of all if white
check sure you come up that doesn't hurt
you at all right if white tries to trade
rooks here what do you do and this is
where knowing your basic King and pawn
in names comes into play because if a
rook trade is threatened in in a rook
game game you have to know whether it's
a draw so for example after rook chase
g6 do you guys know whether that's a
draw or not mmm-hmm yeah
the King comes up and yeah this endgame
is a very simple draw probably most of
you have seen this the key is to go here
of course and yeah ii 7 the key is you
get this position white to move the draw
so that doesn't help that's very
important right otherwise that your rook
could get chased away but as it is your
replica can't just away so eventually
white has to play this move now what do
you do and this is very important the
most important move you've played so far
if you check on b5 I play King of 6 and
now you're in big trouble because I'm
threatening mate and your rook can't
check me right my king is shielded from
checks and here actually you can
basically resign because I'm threatening
mates and if you try to move here or
here I'll just check you and once you
get something like this with the rook
and pawn both covering the queening
square like the pawn threaten between
the rook covering the cleaning square
even if the rook were far away it's
almost always a win because the King can
even approach the rook and I'm just
going to Queen because you can't cover
this square with two pieces you guys see
that and here it's very simple because
the RIP comes here King comes here your
Donald checks so that would be pretty
pretty sad right but the question is why
did you play this move which provokes
white to push the pawn why would you do
something like this there's a very good
reason but you have to figure out what
it is so why would you provoke this pawn
to push there's actually a reason why
the pawn on e6 is actually not very good
ah you're probably not going to take it
your king is actually very good where it
is however your rook is actually not
very good now right
White's threatening to play king of six
you need a move which deals with this
threat
very good so this is the whole point you
provoke the pawn to this square and this
is again something that happens the
endgame a lot in the middle game almost
never which is that you move your rook
back and forth to provoke one move but
why is the pawn here so important for
black what does the pawn do here which
is actually it looks kind of silly
you're provoking a pawn forward but this
actually happens a lot sometimes having
a pond farther advanced is not
necessarily better for that side in this
case having the pawn here
kills a very important part of White's
position what does White's King not have
now there's no shelter in this position
if you if you would immediately started
checking as we saw the King can hide
here right if you try to be sneaky and
go behind or sorry if you try to just
wait for example I'm not going to come
here and let you check me but I'll play
here now if you check me from the side I
have the pawn push if you check me from
here I have this move and now your Kings
got to move right but if you start with
cutting me off on the sixth ring
eventually I have to push my pawn
because otherwise I can't break through
and now your route comes back and now my
King has no shelter from the checks your
rook thinks shield from behind but you
can just trade rooks and go to a draw on
King and pawn in game so there's no way
for me to just stop endless checks until
the King goes way away from the pond so
you see what I mean shelter from checks
is one of the most by far the most
important things to remember from these
endian the King does not have shelter
from checks if the King has to move far
away from wherever the pawn is wherever
the action is it's almost for sure it's
going to be a draw just because I mean
the pond needs the support of the king -
Queen right so you guys understand this
one the Philidor draw I'd say this and
Lucena positions are the two most
important positions in all the brook and
games so if you can learn those
positions no I'm cold that will help you
figure out tougher positions but I'd say
these are two of the most common rook
ending positions like if you play long
enough you will get these positions
eventually for both sides so it's
important to know them cold because the
thing is if you don't know if you don't
know them that well it's harder to
evaluate from going into them like for
example say you'll have a position where
you can trade a pair of pawns or trade a
pair of pieces and you're like okay is
this rook endgame a draw a win what's
going on and it's very important that
you're able to know them ahead of time
because it's hard to calculate this
stuff out right it's a lot of moves I
mean think about it each of these things
is like you know 10 moves right so it's
hard to calculate it all out but if you
know going in what the results going to
be you can evaluate what you're going to
do earlier a lot easier so it's actually
and not only that it helps you figure
out more complicated route getting its I
mean it's just a really useful tool but
it's like the base like you have to have
if you don't have this knowledge it's
going to be harder to acquire other
types of knowledge and rotations so
these are the two positions I'd say by
far the most important so moving on a
little bit so this is one of the key
positions so this is where the passivity
thing comes into play so what's
threatening rook what I almost gave it
away but you guys can say it anyway rook
c8 mates pretty strong threat right so
black has to play rook back to a8 now
this is an example of the passive rook
the reason this rook is passive is
because it just has to sit on the
eighth-ranked there's nothing else this
rook can do right and passive rooks in
again passive rooks and rook and names
almost always death there are exceptions
but for the most part of a rook just has
to sit there never try to check the King
never do anything almost certainly
you're not going to be able to win now
again think about it this way if the
rook we're behind here in our block to
move block could just keep giving checks
right but because the rook is stuck
passive it's actually a very easy win
however there's one maneuver you got to
figure out his wife so see what you can
do
do up at the rap so I'm just going to
sit rook back and forth is my plan not a
very sophisticated plan or fun plan but
that's my plan
aha you got to get the rook on the other
side of the King so you check first if
you play rook h7 then I can play rook
here and pin your pawn so it doesn't
quite work out but if you throw in this
check first it's a very clever check I
have to go here going here doesn't
really make any difference because
you're going to play rook age seven
anyway and now you're threatening mate
if the King runs you just win the rook
if the King goes here you play what game
over okay so passive defense complete
fail right that was three moves that's a
lot easier than building a bridge right
at least on the built in the bridge the
defensive rook is active checking you
passive rook gets slaughtered
immediately there are exceptions though
which are important to know this
position you cannot win rook comes back
nothing you can do the reason why
actually why don't you guys tell me why
would this not be a win but the F pawn
is incidentally you'll find this is
often the case F through C are all very
similar the same rules tend to apply G
pawns tend to be very tricky ER and H
pawns of course tend to be extremely
draw we'll get to that in a bit H pawns
are by far the most draws but what I
mean by that is like okay the games by
like really likely an end in a draw
unless you have some huge advantage like
the Kings cut off by like a million
files basically we'll get to that in a
little bit but for now G pawns
I'm beat pawns are actually very tricky
I'd say they're the trickiest pawns to
learn but in this particular case it
helps black because there's no way to
win why do you think that is what's one
measly file
you might remember the winning technique
from before what was the winning
technique from before mm-hmm all right
so keep so try it the problem is that
you don't have enough room you need to
play rook to i7 here but unfortunately
not quite playable you don't to play g7
of course because and now you actually
lose I'll be highly embarrassing so if
you don't do that though there's no way
to get your rope to the other side right
so the king just sits here the rook goes
back and forth all day black kind of
laughs nothing you can do of course you
can play it out a little bit try some
stuff but it's actually a draw kind of a
bummer all right but this way it works
so passive defense almost always a
disaster that's one of the exceptions if
it's a G pawn or be pon keep in mind G
and B are the same right this is a nice
thing about any games you don't only
have to learn half of the board all
right so this next one this actually
this this this is a painful precision
for me and this is why I was actually on
the black side of this position against
a student of mine who I taught this end
game and he was not able to win it so I
was sitting there at the board going
like this I was like trying not to just
be like no please just win because it's
like I actually showed him this and it
was like you know he told he forgot he
like forgot one little detail he wasn't
able to win it so this position you can
actually force a Lucena position and
which as we know is though is the win so
you have to learn how to force it so
first of all black can't if but the
funny thing is that black could even get
the rook to g8 it would be a draw right
because it's a beep on see that but
there's no way to do it if black tries
rook here
it loses very simply to check and now
you just trade easy enough right so
black has to try to run with the king so
once the King gets out now here
how does white win this is probably the
toughest move to find and this is and
this is actually the funny thing is he
actually found this move but didn't find
the move afterwards which I thought was
really strange but so just to give you
guys a little bit of a little hint so
first of all you'd like to play king a6
but the problem here what do you think
the problem with King a6 is hmm the pawn
Cumberland you're close though not King
c6 but King where yeah and the problem
is now you have to start all over again
you have to play check and then come
back and do the whole thing over again
so that doesn't help you but basically
you want to get your King here and pawn
here right the problem you have is that
if you move your rook here to defend
your pawn the King will slide it in
front if you try to go to the side the
king will come over so you need to use a
very sneaky maneuver here in order to
win
rook h4 I'll still play here remember
the kid if the King gets gets too close
you're probably not gonna be able to do
it it's a really weird-looking move
so if you're looking for moves and you
see one you're like oh that can't be
right that's probably the move Roque
eight is looks like a reasonable [ __ ]
what happens if I play here and just sit
remember you always have to consider
what am I going to do if my opponent
sits for both sides actually so it's a
common thing in the endgame you can but
again the king is going to run here the
second you move you could try something
like this but then here and the rook
can't move I mean it's kind of not
really working out for you right I think
eventually he did that and that's how we
drew but okay it's actually rook b8
that's a hard move to find right but try
to figure out the purpose so first of
all if the rook moves anywhere along
here like say rook a 1 now you can play
what again your goal is to get the pawn
to b7 so how do you do that if you play
king c5 again remember the checks right
b7 and you're going to play pawn here
rook over King here pawn here right so I
decided to try what I thought was the
best practical attempt I played here or
just kept the rook on the file but what
option did you give yourself now that
you played rook b8 what move do you have
here which was not an option before king
1/6 and king c7 again and it's the same
problem but you found an extra square
for yourself by playing rook b8 and this
is the move for some reason he just
blanked on this move I mean it happens
to very strong players it's not it's not
that surprising but
rook d7 then the king again we'll go to
see Athens
it's the same problem again your goal is
to push the pawn so you want to get your
King out of the way
but King b7 doesn't work King a6 and
King c7 so what moved you play ha
and this was the move that he forgot the
whole point is that now if I check from
the side you played a b7 and you win the
same way
get your pawn to b6 once you get your
pawn to b6 it's easy to advance at the
rest of the way because you're actually
very well shielded so here ah yeah and
here there's nothing you can do so King
a7 if King c7 you give this check it's
very important move to have as well so
you see how this rook looked really
weird but somehow it actually turned out
to be very useful so then the King would
move and now you can even you're going
to move the rook over and it's it's
you're actually going to get the exact
Lucena position so just to test you guys
because I'm not a nice person how do you
guys win
oh yeah you got it down the first time I
showed you you nailed it what's the
technique you use building what a bridge
right not a cannon not a highway it's a
bridge so I don't even know why it's
building a bridge but that's what they
call so so what do you do first where do
you need your rook first of all okay so
what do you do so one trick to note is
that the rook ever moves like say I play
here you can win very simply by putting
your rook here and then sliding your
King over and you see how the rook
shield you from checks here and then the
pawn is going to just Queen there's no
defense to that for example if the rook
goes here you can you have a few ways
you can do it but you can play here and
then give this check and then get a
queen or if you want to be fancy about
it you can even get a queen here and
then check if you want to be fancy not
not necessary but it's kind of nice
because it's all all checks but but okay
so say say instead I just sit
hmm rook d4 check
so if king c6 got this one right so I'm
going to play King here and now
seven so if I play king e5 you can just
go here and that's the easiest way
rook here also wins okay I'm going to
give a check
mm-hmm
so if I give a check you come here right
now go look here
I'm not I never advertise myself as such
so I don't feel like I'm betraying any
expectations yeah I mean there are a few
ways to win you can even play like rook
c4 King c7 but yeah rip d5 is the nicest
because now you're just going to shield
very nice good job you you succeeded
where my 2200 student failed not joking
so you guys are experts already alright
um yeah it was actually really painful
because it's like at the same time I
don't want to lose the game but I also
don't want him not to win it because
it's like we just worked on it so as I
go but anyway um yeah it was tough but
this is the tricky maneuver right rook
be Aiden King beat King King a7 not
obvious but you see how once you it's
much easier to find if you know you're
aiming for once you know the Lucena you
don't have to worry about winning that
position you just have to worry about
getting to it once you get there you'll
be able to win it you might have to
spend a couple minutes I'm not saying
you have to blitz it out but you might
have to spend a few minutes but at least
you'll know it's a win you'll know
you're there it might take a while I
mean it's hard to recognize all these
positions right away but the way you
were able to get there is a little bit
tricky but once you knew what you were
aiming for it makes a lot easier to find
so the next one
so this one is actually really pretty
tricky so with white to move if you use
this this technique it's actually a draw
with best play but this is very tricky
stuff so first of all what is it black
going to play if it were black smooth
what would black play rook g6 right and
you cut off the 6th and if the pawn
pushes then you go back right go back
check endlessly but it's White's move so
you're white so again even if you know
it's a draw
you always want to make your opponent
prove it you want to make them find as
many good moves as possible so say
you're white here it's still a draw
let's say you knew it you know your rook
end game's cold you're like yeah I got
this but you know what to draw but you
still want to challenge them so how do
you challenge them the most and trust me
almost all of your opponents will not
know this and you will probably win so
yeah so what's the most challenging move
I showed you this technique before but
it was a slightly different position I
like to mix the pawn around by the way
just because people get too used to
doing it on one side of the board and
then they get to the other side of the
board they're like whoa what's going on
even though it's the same so I like to
move the pawn around just to confuse you
guys again never said I was a nice
person so king c6 is possible but the
problem is that there's rook check and
the King has to move back and you put
the rook where it wants to go right so
you have to be a little bit more subtle
aha
so the threat now so the thought now is
to give check right so believe it or not
so here it already gets kind of tricky
the best defense is actually not to
check but to put the rook behind the
pawn the reason being that now if white
gives a check here the King comes up and
you can't really do much you can't push
the pawn black starting to check the
King do they file which is certainly
going to be a draw so really black white
would just have to go back rook check
here King goes here doesn't do anything
but White's whole idea was to provoke
the rook to but to go behind the pawn in
order to play this move so white says ha
ha ha but now consider this to the
b-pawn position within the b-pawn
position the King had to go out here
right so one of the problems with the
King out there so for example if the
King goes this way and you do this
maneuver this is actually a win the
reason being is that this King will
block checks if the rook tries to check
from the side the king will block it so
one of the main things to remember in
this position this is again one of the
most important positions you can face
here go to the short side the short side
meaning the edge of the board it looks a
little weird at first but the main idea
is that you need a place to check from
so remember a lot of the positions that
determining whether they're wins or
draws is by whether the King is
sheltered from rook checks so if you're
your own King can actually be a
hindrance because it blocks your your
rook from getting checked from giving
checks so compare that to go so compare
this King d8 to going to the short side
so let's say black tries the same
maneuver so black just plays like rook
da rook here you just sit the rook ever
comes up you play King back right so
white tries this one but now and look at
all these lovely files you have to check
from and they're open you don't have a
king here blocking your rook and that's
what makes the difference so this
position is actually just a draw because
you can check endlessly from the side
but there are still some tricks not that
many I mean for example
comes here you don't want to give checks
because then the king will come up
believe it or not that still a draw but
you have to be more precise we're not
really going to get into that you can
simply bring the rope back if the King
ever moves here you come here but the
main thing to remember is that the
second the rook the second white
threatens King D seven you slide your
rook over and check from the side so
make sense to you guys
all right so I'm going to show you one
more which is kind of a cool one to show
and then I'm going to give you a few
problems where you actually have to use
the knowledge that you've acquired and
mastered thus far so the eighth pawn so
I wanted to talk about it a little so
you guys wouldn't go play a game and
then you're like wait but he never even
mentioned in a pond or a rook pawn huh
so rook pawns are so hard to win with
because it's hard to find shelter
because the King the King can't even
move to the side of the board right so
the King you know it's so much like you
get a position like this and the rook
cuts off the King completely the King
can't even move so in order to win so
for example let's again use white would
never play this move but let's say you
had this even here with the King cut off
for files you cannot win it's amazing
but the rook the King will simply sit
and if you try to bring your rook around
once the King gets here you have no hope
because the King just never lets this
King out so for example rook here you
just play rook here and then the rook
will just sit and you just do this
forever and white cannot do anything
white tries to check you from the side
you just say nope and this King is never
getting out basically so you know why
can check you forever but you're just
never letting go and there's no hope so
then eventually white will play here and
give up just for fun so just for fun
this actually happened in the game of
land believe it or not my opponent did
that at the end just for kicks
he did it with a smile on his face but
in this position you need five files and
this is enough to win and it's with a
really cool sequence so this is how it
goes
rook comes to the side
rook here so you need to put the rook
here is the key trying to go to b7
doesn't quite work because if you go to
b7 I come out and you can't bring your
King out because checkmate embarrassing
right it's easy to get embarrassed in
these positions let me tell you so R
okay Jade King tries to come closer so
if the King comes here it's actually
rather straightforward because you play
rook here the King gets out and now how
do you win I keep giving checks but what
can you work in your King run this is
one of the cases where the king can
actually go far away from the rook and
pawn because do you remember this
pattern with the pawn and rook here or
the rook covering the 8th and the pawn
rate of the Queen so all I need is to
get one move to Queen my pawn and even
if your regards it I just win a rook
right so the King can just run out this
way and okay you can keep giving checks
but eventually I will chase your rook
down right that was that
however block can be much more annoying
which of course I'm going to be and play
this move so you can try the same move
so it doesn't really matter where the
rook moves that much King gets out but
now coming out this way doesn't work you
don't have enough space because this
King guards this square so if you try to
come out this way you just can't do it
because the rook has to guard the pawn
and once again if the King tries to come
out here you see how you just lose the
pawn so the only way to try to do it is
to go this way which looks easy enough
you go here
rook here and you're like what's the big
deal right
the Kings sheltered right but now I play
here threatening mate believe it or not
this isn't so simple so incidentally if
the rook tries to go here it doesn't
really work out because I play King here
and after check you don't quite have
enough room but if I go all the way to
the edge of the board you can't go out
this way because in this position what
do I do
hmm the rooks hanging right the pawns
ready to queen you only have one chance
yeah and then you can take the pawn so
you can't escape this way so the only
try is to check the King I play here and
this is the really cool part so the
problem you have is if you try to go
here then I'm going to give you give you
checks so for example here check and you
can't come out here because I'll check
here so you have to go here
check approach my rook and now I'll come
here and if here then I come here and
you're too far away I force the rook
back and now you're going to lose this
pawn see that so you have to be a bit
more clever so what move do you think
you have here it's actually a really
cool move
mmm very nice so if King takes rook you
clean with check you should be able to
check and win this rook I'm pretty sure
but even if not okay you have queen
against rook it's another story entirely
but it is a win and the nice thing here
so if the rook king goes here now you
can come back and the difference is you
have an escape route so for example if I
check you can come here and if I try to
check you this way you can run away like
this and if I go here now you can
actually castle sort of you play rook
here got a check yep but now once again
your King has shelter your king has
extra space and it's over you're just
going to get a queen next that wasn't
complicated at all right we see how
crazy these gets even with the rook King
cut off five files you have to be this
precise in order